I gotta the writer last good morning
everybody welcome to the second or third
meeting of scrutiny in January of this
year and there's a bit of echo going on
but I'm not sure why that's the case
still we'll work it out
welcome to the COO scrutiny meeting
first I've got to remind everybody the
domestic arrangements toilets are
situated outside the meeting room cold
water is available in the breakout area
will so outside the meeting room if the
fire alarm should sound please leave the
meeting room by following the fire exit
signs and meeting on the Ipswich Town
Football Club training pitch please do
not use the atrium stairs to exit the
building and do not re-enter the
building until you are told it is safe
to do so please switch off all more
mobile phones or turn them to silent I'd
like to remind everybody that this
meeting will is being a will be
broadcast live to the Internet and will
be capable of repeated viewing whole of
the meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting well it doesn't look like that's
going to happen today but you'll be
deemed by the council to have consented
to being filmed by entering this room
you're also consenting to being filmed
by the council and to the possible use
of those images and sound recordings for
webcasting and/or training purposes so
we come to the first item on the agenda
which is apologies and substitutes good
morning we have received apologies from
councillor Brandon okay second item on
the agenda is declarations of interest
do I have any or do we have any
declarations of interests take that as a
no then
that's definitely rubbish matters they
should be item three is item four rather
and receive notifications of petitions
in accordance with the council's
petition scheme none received and item 4
is questions by the public none received
question item 5 is questions by
councillors non-receipt chair so we come
to the first paper in the first
substantive item item 6 on the agenda is
BOS 19 stroke 5 which is the draft
general budget for 2020 21 and the
four-year outlook for that year and for
succeeding 3 so I'll ask
councillor John Waters the cabinet
member for finance to introduce the
paper before handing on to officers
Thank You chair I'm pleased think used
report vos 19 5 for the 2020 to 2021
general fund budget and the full-year
outlook the report contains details of
the draft revenue and capital budgets
and the council strategic financial aim
now we do have a sound financial
strategy that does respond effectively
to the changing funding landscape for
local government this aims principles
and approach are set out in section 6 of
the report but in summary we must
continue with our efforts become
self-sufficient through maximizing our
income streams continue to make
efficiencies and productivity savings
and continue to find new ways of working
just as by way of a bit of an
introduction that the government has
confirmed the fair funding review and
the business rate review and the
business rates reset have all been
deferred by 12 months to 2021 to 2022
however we do have a recently announced
provisional financial settlement for the
forthcoming year which does give us an
additional funding of 265 thousand
pounds details of this are provided in
Section four point fourteen and the
report now I did mention before your
outlook the general fund budget setting
is just a part of producing a
medium-term outlook for our finances
which is both successful and sustainable
and so there has been a lot of time
spent on projecting the four year
outlook
and the details of the funding
preciousness a missing it can for the
next four years are provided in sections
eight point two to eight point eighteen
quarter the funding is the need to have
a strong council tax base and therefore
from the perspective of the four-year
outlook the numbers do produce a
compelling case for the need for council
tax increases each year and so for
twenty twenty to twenty twenty-one we
will do this at the maximum level
allowed without requiring a referendum
IE five pounds per year for an average
bandi property in this equation three
point one percent we will be reducing
this to two percent thereafter but along
with the most welcome two point five one
percent growth and a ban de equivalent
number of properties for the past year
and one point five percent per annum
thereafter this will ensure we can grow
our castle tax revenues to help offset
the ongoing cost pressures we face and
together these will provide three
hundred eight thousand pounds of
additional income for 2020 to 2021
now since 2011 to 2012 the castle has
achieved cumulative savings in income of
seventeen point four million pounds
through shared services efficiencies
better use of technology and maximizing
commercial opportunities thereby
vindicating the bold decisions that have
been made in that period further savings
an income of 2.6 million pounds have
already been identified for next year
and beyond and the details of these are
provided in the section of eight point
eighteen the general fund budget
requires five hundred and twelve
thousand pounds of the 2020 to 2021 new
homes bonus receipts 1.2 million pounds
of section 31 grants 227,000 pounds of
rural service delivery grant and three
hundred four thousand pounds from our
earmarked reserves in order to achieve a
balanced budget it should be noted here
that three hundred four thousand pounds
from reserves is only half the amount we
transferred last year and the good news
is that only 49% of the anticipate new
homes bonus will be required which will
enable to transfer the rest the
transformation fund and the details of
new homes bonus funding are provided in
sections eight point six to eight point
ten of the report the overall budget gap
for the period for this period is
described as such as 819 to a to two
and in your report in front of you and
Matt's accumulative 1.3 2 million pounds
a significant income or savings all both
will be needed to address this the good
news however is that we are predicting a
budget surplus of 542 thousand pounds
which bit which is the unused note new
hands bonus that will go to the
transformation fund now I did have a bit
of an update actually honors those
numbers in that 542 thousand pounds a
surplus has increased now to five
hundred eighty four thousand pounds and
the cumulative number has yeah it's one
point the cubes new number is now one
point one two five million pounds as
opposed to one point three two million
so those are hot off the press updates
okay right the reserve levels are
detailed in paragraph seven point five
table three and while we had to use a
large amount for the 2019 to 2020 budget
thanks to the new homes bonus
contribution the level at the end of
March 2021 is expected to be to improve
with a transformation fund a much
healthier or your number there is eight
hundred and forty eight thousand pounds
but it'll be near to nine hundred
thousand pounds as a result of the
increase in in the surplus this year
even with this improvement the level of
reserves excluding sill drops by 10%
over the two years from March 2019 to
2021 and this does require close
attention in the future the capital
program is set out in Appendix B and the
plans burn for 2020 to 2021 is talk like
1 million pounds but a gain that there
are some changes to that we're on
appendix B pended yeah so that changed
now is the capital program has reduced
to eleven point five million pounds for
the forthcoming year
all right so the main area is just under
a million pounds on housing grants eight
point seven million pounds investment in
Cisco and just under a million pounds on
the continuation of the refurbishment of
the two laser centers the three major
differences from this time last year are
that we're not expecting to complete the
further system Cisco investment until
2021 to 2022 now the Bellevue capital
investment has been delayed until 2021
to 2022 and we have yet to dip into the
speedy the strategic land of property
investment fund the capital and
investment strategy will have further
details of the council's borrowing
capacity and the impacts of the capital
program and this will be presented to
cabinet in February along with a final
budget report following a review by the
joint order the Standards Committee
finally will be making changes to the
empty property discount the background
to this is explained in sections 11
point one till eleven point seven and we
will keep the level of discount for
unoccupied and unfurnished properties at
twenty five percent but reduce the
period from three months to twenty eight
days after which full council taxes
payable the uninhabitable discount will
remain unchanged at 25 percent for
twelve months this has been in place in
2018 we would have raised the further
fifty three thousand powers in council
tax so that gives you some some context
of the the amount of money involved
there and so that that term concludes my
report
right I don't know if any officers want
to add anything to that if there's any
points that they think need to be
brought forward for members of deep
committee no shakes of heads all around
so so then members it's over to us to
raise any questions we have regarding
this paper and regarding the appendices
or any other parts now it strikes me
that the possible approach we could take
here is looking at the report and the
structure of it we have initially a
statement of what the current financial
situation is what arrangements have been
made for central government the external
pressure
if you like that includes changes to the
new homes bonus from that and our own
internal finances our own cost brushes
then lead us presumably I think in extra
Blake to the decisions that have been
made which are listed in the
recommendation those being the council
tax rise the changes to discounts and
just some other variation things so are
there any of those points that you'd
like to bring up and ask questions on
please dad all rush at once okay I
wonder I voted the first thing I've
noted about the budget paper as a whole
I mean particularly the general fund
budget this seemed a great deal simpler
in design and construction as a paper
than perhaps we'd seen in previous years
I don't know if that's necessarily a
question but I wonder if you could
comment on that Katherine the content
and style for the this year is similar
to last year but we did make a conscious
effort last year to change the structure
they Melissa and the team did put a lot
of effort into that with feedback that
we'd had to to try and make it easier to
read should I say so yes that was a
conscious decision well I can recall in
the past in great watches of paper
having been presented to us most of
which made very little sense this by
comparison makes a great deal more I
think there's a couple of things I think
that need to be brought out in the
meeting and I think they need to be
better understood by counselors and
members of the public Mary Thank You
chair yes this business about the very
early the press release
the increase in in the council tax which
i thought he understood and then went to
my parish council meetings and realized
that nobody understood it and i've had
to do some homework as a result of that
so I think that the when press releases
are made to the public I think he has to
be a bit simpler and explain in context
so what they read was that paper
District Council were putting five
pounds per annum and Pingle assumed it
was on the total amount rather than the
amount that actually beverage is taken
rather than bandy oh yes I see what
you're saying old council so we had a
discussion about what was 3% and if I
found certainly wasn't 3% of AB and E
which might be 1800 council award yeah
this is a perennial problem
unfortunately because we are the
collecting authority we collect on
behalf of the county the police and
crime Commissioner and and also we
collect the parish precepts as well we
do try to stress each time that we are
talking purely about that the beta
proportion so that five pounds puts up
the average bandy property to 168 pounds
86 pence per annum and that is a three
percent rise on that bay-buh proportion
and we we do try to stress this all the
time but unfortunately because as the
collecting authority we collect all
these other elements and all they see is
a total although there is a breakdown on
on their council tax bills which we
start show what is baver what a suffer
etc we do have to explain this this each
year unfortunately it's it's one of
those things where we do our best but
there's it's going to keep cropping up
now some of that matter is it possible
though for some example
to be given I don't know how you do that
but some example because once you look
at the the the training we had Catherine
on the on the division you understand it
but the public don't get that sort of
explanation and of course what is a
surprise is that the District Council
amount is quite small in comparison to
everybody else that has a piece of the
action so I think that would come as a
surprise to the public as a figure I do
every year I must admit myself I've been
doing this is the last few years a
breakdown in percentage terms but I've
actually managed to reduce it to it this
is again as an approximation as well
last year and I don't see there being a
massive difference between last year
across the area all the various
authorities in this one but roughly
speaking it's about twenty four pounds a
week on a bandy property this is the
average size property in fact it's
actually slightly above the average size
property but it's 24 pounds a week is
your payment to Suffolk County Council I
think it works out at four pounds a week
to the police and crime Commissioner
three pounds a week to the District
Council that is to say us and roughly 1
pound reading less a week to your parish
preset so that's one three four twenty
four three-quarters of the council tax
total is actually for Suffolk County
Council and that percentage it may be in
fact we 74 power 7 T 4% but I believe
those are fairly accurate figures and
that that's a rule of thumb one three
four twenty four and that's something
I've used for some time and I think it
makes it understandable amount and
that's per week okay so it's x 52 and
you have the annual figure of more or
less
I'll see what we can do in terms of
providing more clarity to to residents
when their bills go out it's as I say
there's something we have to struggle
with every year but you're right there
on those numbers with Baber been just
over three pounds a week it's incredibly
good learning for money do we just do so
much for that I know it's a bit of a
propaganda exercise this but I mean even
if all we did was to empty the bins
it'll be good value for money but we do
everything else as well on top of that
as the planning authority in terms of
provision of leisure facilities the
Licensing Authority I could go on but
but what we'll see what we can do in
terms of providing more clarity to
residents definitely council MacLeod
could I ask whether there is any we have
at the May election we had a change of
parish councilors and I think that
perhaps has led to some not everybody
understands the concept is that it's a
training for parish councillors around
so we don't do training for all the
parish council councillors obviously
we've got 200 across the two districts
but what we are doing is the next parish
passion Town Council briefing early
February I'm going long to do a budget
slot so those who long for that briefing
but now they'll get some headlines and
information about our budget position
speaking speaking as a parish council of
some years south the Suffolk Association
of local councils does in fact provides
counselor training and can provide
targeted training I think a lot of it I
mean I've found in my own experience
that particularly having since becoming
a district councillor as well the
insight of the two and notice that we
have councillor Osborne with us here
today and other councillor Osborn
councillor Osborn
and you'd like to say something there
Thank You mr. chairman on that subject
perhaps we could ask the chairman of the
cell group councillor Adrienne Osborne
to raise that that they could bring that
training forward as a priority perhaps
it's a bit late for this particular
budget but for future budgets that would
be a good idea
thank you very much councillor Osborne
for reminding me that the other
councillor Osborne is in fact the
chairman of south for us so Adrienne
would you like to add anything to that
yes thank you care service board yes
so we'll identify any issues that
parishes and towns have and there is
training available there's quite a long
list of stuff that they will train on so
yes parishes in towns will be able to
use silk as a training tool for that and
if I may mr. chairman I'd just like to
ask Catherine nor Jean the position with
the presets as we go on I've found that
we've had a lot from from our town
council about the arrangements for the
budget and how the budget then actually
holds back
parish and towns arrangements for their
preset is there any way that obviously
it's all and I very much respect what
you've done over the years and your
finance offices is there any other way
that yeah a little bit further was the
word for it to be able to bring forward
some of the precepts from Bebo so that
the town and parishes will be able to
know what their preset has got to be
when they do their bring their financed
forward to you so there's a question of
when the the tax base figures released
and and people can start the
calculations for their own parish
council budgets is that what we're
talking about correct those parish and
town council budgets that we're looking
at and how we can relate those to the
babe mr. chairman the the problem is it
does make the time gap between between
these things quite tight for the town's
impact yes I understand the point you're
making just check in what that while
dependencies are in terms of when we can
do those those calculations and we do
have to do what's called a council tax
base return in October each year and
it's after that but we can then do the
individual parish and time council tax
base calculations so I know we usually
get them out in November start all the
end but we obviously do have to submit
that October return first before we come
out and then go on so I think we
probably would struggle to bring it
forward a huge amount you know we'll
have a look see if we can shave in a
week or two off it but I think in terms
of trying to bring it forward a month or
two I don't think we've got that
opportunity because of the government
return that we have to do
yeah councillor Osborne yeah thank you
thank you for that Katherine no I mean
the obvious the obvious situation there
is that when you've got four councils at
parish and towns obviously that comes up
but they cannot go lot forward on some
of those issues because we don't know
what favours pretty situation is with
their with their budget but I quite
understand it and I would just like to
add that council MacLaren's comments
about a more of a an output for
residents to know exactly where they
stand with it were their thing I think
if you attend to that I would become a
fantastic thank you
I just don't know to an observation and
passing that this is actually something
we may be referring to coming back to in
a later item on today's agenda which is
to look at our forward plan that may
address some of your points in passing I
just mentioned that I had a specific
query which had been bothering me
because it's just a significant part
not so much this year's budget this
year's budget actually does quite nicely
after this factor and it's changes in
the arrangements of the new homes bonus
now the new homes bonuses obviously has
been in existence for many years now I
forget it's 2010 it started now it would
be about right that would be I think
there was a general election that year
and we've had it sort of since and it's
steadily risen built up to a maximum of
2016 2017 in terms of how many years it
lasted and then the number of years has
progressively been reduced and now it's
and it's disappearing effectively and I
just wondered the context of that some
explanation of what the national context
is for new homes bonus and what might
replace it because it's if it doesn't
affect this year's budget according to
these figures it will affect us for the
next four years at the moment in terms
of what might replace it I think we've
had the clearest signal from the
government though that new homes bonus
is going they have said there will be a
housing incentive but that's all we've
had so far and they've made a comment
that it's more likely to be linked to
planning I know in the past they have
thought about reducing the amount of new
homes bonus that got paid if you were
allowing planning permissions on appeal
rather than the first time so whether
they're thinking of something along
those lines but again I don't know how
much money nationally they might put
towards new homes bonus because 2021 is
the last year of the current
comprehensive spending review we don't
have any national totals beyond that so
just to put that into perspective that
count since the housing incentive the
new house bonus is based upon completion
of those houses do you think they're
thinking of it actually being done on
the granting of permission and how would
that be paid for was it I was already
hypothetical I do appreciate that it's
still worth asking I don't know
to say we're waiting the provisional
settlement said that they would consult
on their proposals for what will replace
new homes bonus so I don't know what
that's going to be at the end of last
week I did submit our response to the
provisional settlement consultation and
the questions they were asking and in
that did just urge them to consult
quickly on that rather than leaving it a
long time then that gives us longer to
plan ahead counselor would leave make
sure that committee members can be
assured that the District Council's
network is loving very hard for the
continuation of some sort of housing
delivery incentive you host bonus is a
key part of central funding now for
councils and we were losing a lot of
other sources of funding so all councils
do need this in one form or another we
do understand that it's it has to be
linked to delivery of housing so there
is some strong lobbying from the DCM to
to ensure that there is going forward
the proper and incentivized funding
mechanism in place and I would guess
another government association will also
be involved yes so yes so just just to
add something to that and the current
new Holmes bonus does get split between
the two tiers of local authority so we
get 80 percent of the current sums of
money in the county council get 20
percent the LGA obviously represents
both tiers
yes local authorities and whether the
government may do something between the
tiers obviously and pressures are all
being around social care for adults and
children as well so if the government
makes changes they might actually change
how the allocations are done between the
different tiers of authorities as well
so that may go against us yes and
similarly with any change to business
rates if there is an increase in the 75
percent business rates retention there
will undoubtedly be some sort of bonfire
between counties and districts over the
apportioning there but there's a there's
a lot there's a lot to be discussed and
a lot to be lobbied for I may hear some
more of the DCN annual conference next
month but I think that might be a bit
too soon I think this is probably it's
fair to say one of the more difficult
years since we have a change of least
style of government in some ways and
clearly there are different ideas going
to be applying of course I don't think
we've ever had such a febrile political
situation for very many years the only
thing I think we haven't addressed is
yet and I think it needs to be is
whenever increases are being talked
about or changes the changes to the
doctor discounts that were discussed and
are inherent in the budget now I
appreciate that you said if we'd been
charging these we would have been
something like 58,000 pounds this year
but I just wonder if you could give some
rationale to the reasons behind the
decisions for the changes in the
unoccupied and unfurnished discounts
well we want to encourage properties to
come back into use essentially and if
something is unoccupied not furnished
but habitable we don't want to provide
continuing incentives to to leave it
like that we want to be able to ensure
that the properties are brought back
into use we have a housing shortage we
want to see as few unoccupied properties
as possible well that was six inked
thanks very much okay for me rather more
16th in the question counseling the
Clara thank you
[Music]
yeah sorry I don't obviously and I'm
probably asking a question that you
already know but what is the the check
on I mean how often does the council
connect with these people on these
properties is there a regular update on
the situation or the status of an
unoccupied property I think we actually
have the opportunity to ask this from
two particular sections one from the
offices its present here and also from
cancer Osborn who's the cabinet member
for housing legit but I think both sides
can explain how the housing team deals
of those situations who would like first
crack at this one
Gavin welcome to this Thank You Jay last
question um just analysis of question a
report is issued to the private sector
housing team on a reasonably regular
basis and they review properties that
are either going on to that empty homes
list or or coming off it and obviously
they used that as the list of properties
that they then target through grants and
loans to support some of those homes
coming back into use if the earnest
leader systems answer McClaren again is
that a sort of face to face or is it so
by email enforcement of so the private
sector housing team is is currently only
made up of free private sector housing
officers current review of that service
going on at the moment
so typically correspondence would
initially be in the form of a letter or
some sort of written correspondence just
because they can't publicly contact and
a face to face everyone so it is at that
stage a paper but should they get in at
rest should they get contacts then
obviously they would go out and and
formally meet
and review the property and make
decisions counselor sorry counselor
McLaren and then I'll come but counselor
Oswald wanted to add to that which way
should we do this
counselor Osborne answers the first
question and Mary can come back with the
second one does that work go for it then
Jack Thank You mr. chairman and yeah I
do actually represent the Council on the
shared revenue partnership and we get
quarterly reports from them on the work
that's being done on empty properties
and they're very productive in that and
they do a lot of work they do act a lot
on the intelligence as well as their own
piece of work but so there's two sides
that you got the housing team doing
their piece of work and the shared
revenue partnership as well councillor
McLaren yes I was just going to go back
to if I have if I've got quite a lot of
money as a property owner is this a
threat to me to occupy the property the
you know the access of the cows or do
does it have a lot of power to make
changes so first and foremost I think
our approach would always be one to try
and support the owner to return the
property to use there will be always a
number of extenuating circumstances why
that property is empty and empty for a
period of time some of the impact is as
a result of being coming incidental
owners so through bereavement or through
those type of means a person becomes the
owner of a house but doesn't know
necessarily what to do with it so that
that's an example the examples with
private sector housing is initially
loans and grants to support it being
returning into use obviously there is
always the opportunity that we could
take enforcement action but that would
always be be a very last resort and then
through the work of the housing
solutions team more widely obviously
trying to fix that housing crisis in
terms of number of people on on our
Housing Register and
homelessness we do look to offer support
to those landlords to perhaps support
them in terms of finding a tenant for
those properties and we've got work
coming forward in the early part of this
year which we'll be launching in April
which will go further to support
landlords in in terms of attracting
tenants and maintaining them Catholic
Karen do you as a department publish the
list of reasons or give the percentage
of unoccupied properties the reasons why
there are knocking idea is that
something that you produce
I think we're straying slightly off the
subject um perhaps we can deal with that
in another accent as I believe we've got
an item actually on occupancy of housing
here and and we will be coming back to
that but I'd like to keep this to a
budget discussion I know that's quite I
think you're quite right to raise it
because effective it's worth reiterating
that this proposed change is that we're
reducing the period of time for which we
offer this discount for from three
months to 28 days effectively one
month's so that's an important
distinction to make we're not removing
it completely the principle is still
already established all we're really
arguing about is the time councillor
Dawson just sort of wandering out of
interest how this works with places like
and I think we like to bring it up
there's a bit of Hornets nests but where
you've got the situation places like
Angel course and they're all in the
budget and that's been you know going on
and on for five or six years so are we
again putting that into this year's
budget and it might not happen and I
just wonder how these figures have been
what's been happening in previous years
and how that's reflected in the finances
here it's not Celtic but there must be
several like this across Baber I'm just
choosing that long as this happens to be
my ward but how are those figures
reflecting is that good I think that's
necessarily categorizes an unoccupied
unfurnished building I think that's well
okay not that could take we've got a lot
of buildings
we across that we you know I I just saw
what I'm trying to get to grips with is
what you're doing with the figures with
these unoccupied when there are plans
for things to commence it actually don't
start and they're being put into the
budget that's my understanding or is
that wrong
let's just let's establish whether we've
got here and we got an unoccupied
building or we got a separate category
which refers for example to Angel courts
that may be you know there are lots of
other buildings and thinking sub green
hat Hadley were you know cross baby
where the figures are being put in and
they're not actually occupied and they
have been vacant for long periods of
time so I'm just wondering what happened
in the previous years and going forward
what's happening with the figures for
these terms of canceled taxes are we're
talking about cancer tax here and the
reduction in the discount where we have
our own social housing where that is
unoccupied for a period of time then it
would be subject to the same discount
obviously the housing team have been
working very hard to get the void days
and the void time down so it is now
within the 28 days that we are proposing
so if you've got buildings that sort of
meant to be you know finished this year
and perhaps they're not how is that
reflected in the figures or isn't it
going forward I don't think I quite
understand the question so people say
for instance I didn't know what's their
nature court that was meant to be
finished in February and you're
expecting the income to be generated or
spent or whatever and it isn't are those
figures in these figures here or not
really
that's angel corts a development site
it's not completely it's not an
unoccupied or unfurnished yes but there
are others wherever they are well I try
to ascertain here all these figures in
here and then it's
not no okay I think again I think it's
very really difficult because I think
any time and it's quite true it always
has been any time we talk about the
subject of housing it can mean so many
different things in different contexts
this context is the budget and I don't
think it necessarily means anything here
I did refer to the fact we will be
looking at an occupancy rates and other
aspects of housing policy in scrutiny
much as the housing team do on a regular
or almost a daily basis I would imagine
any other questions members or comments
or anything you want to cover in this
section of papers Council endorsing your
microphone is still on is there anything
you want to do that's all right it
always gets me I think it's the one on
the right okay so we come now to listen
suggested recommendations for this paper
caps
it would be worth turning to those and
seeing if those recommendations are ones
you would wish to consider or whether
that you would want to alter them change
them in any way or add any further
recommendations or remove all of them I
don't know let's have a discussion
recommendations by the way in the paper
in front of you were the same ones that
were given to cabinet we can make up any
recommendations we wish ourselves these
are just guidelines as to what Cabinet
had considered and I believe at the last
cabinet these will all pass their mind
this is a draft general budget so we are
still in the process of forming the
budget and the input scrutiny gives goes
back to cabinet for them to consider
whether we have added anything or
whether I made any changes and
suggestions for the cabinet to consider
before it goes to council so any
thoughts okay
Thank You mr. chairman first of all I
would agree with the recommendations
here on all three three points and
learning is a formalism and the reason
for this decision on it it's coming back
to cabinet anyway and so I I just like
to compliment the finance team Catherine
and Melissa and her team for a good
report and obviously hopefully if
anything changes
they will come forward to budget thank
you are you proposing then that we
endorse all three of those
recommendations I do I do I do mr.
chairman thank you I can't see any
reasons for us to scrutinize any further
positions on this earth because it will
come back to cabinet and therefore we
will be told about it hopefully I I have
to confess and I think we have looked at
this and we're going to look at this
again but I mean I'm inclined to second
the motion
and I'm doing so simply because as chair
and I'm gonna be looking at this again I
will make an observation or two though
in doing so every year the budget comes
through and every year we find ourselves
almost up till the last minute
scrambling around for those last tens
and twenties and sometimes hundreds of
thousands and very often it's been the
case that they've only just turned up
after after the draft that stage and
only just before adoption of the budget
this year is the first time I can recall
in the last four or five where that
hasn't been the case where we actually
have a position that shows a surplus and
I have to confess it from figures given
by a council award today a surplus that
looks as though they could even change a
little bit upwards because there's some
movements in the figures already and
again that's an interesting point
one of the principles though I think and
I would
caution members like this is just a
general observation I'm still seconding
the motion is that the pressures in the
next three years are a lot more
uncertain but as I pointed out
previously I think somewhere else that
we'd we'd thought this year was going to
be the tough here at the moment it looks
like next year's going to be the tough
year maybe next year we'll say something
about the year following I don't know
I'm happy to second that any other
comments or questions or any discussion
councillor Osbourne thank you anything
to add to that other than that obviously
in the next three is hopefully you will
still be there well I mean since we're
not there's not another election for
this council for 2023 that covers us for
three years anyway so we'll just have to
hope that I don't fall under a bus in
the meantime
so then we've got all the various points
recommendations being proposed and
seconded excuse me yet before we vote
can I just make sure that we say that
that we could totally agree that it is
the that you the ovule inscription
committee endorsed recommendation one
point or three point one two three point
three would you like to include and
compliment the finance team on the work
conducted for the budget was concluded
in the thing and I would certainly happy
to second that because it says actually
I say a simpler piece of work actually I
think it's also one that the general
public might be able to understand
rather better than would have been the
case in the past councillor McLaren
might have doubts about that but believe
me it was a lot worse than the past Mary
okay so can we take a show of hands on
that proposal proposal there's a favor
that's carried unanimously
okay thank you very much members we'll
move on to the next item on the agenda
there we go and the paper is BOS 16:9
which is the draft housing revenue
account HRA budget and once again the
four year outlook so once again I asked
councillor Ward as the cabinet members
and Finance to introduce the payment
thanks Jim I'm pleased to introduce
report BOS nineteen at six for the 2020
to 2021 HRA budget and for their outlook
it covers both the HIA revenue account
and the capital program we have a sound
30-year business plan which has resulted
in favorable positions for both revenue
and capital for 2020 to 2021 we have
been helped by the ending of the annual
1% rent reduction imposed by the welfare
reform and work act 2016 the action now
allows rents to be increased by CPI
which is currently at 1.7 percent plus
1% for five years from 2020 to 2021 the
remaining 25 years of the business plan
are based on an annual rent a creep
increase of CPI only the business plan
is attached to dependents B and shows
additional detail for years one to ten
section six point two of the report
shows the predicted movement in the
reserves over the next ten years it
shows a slight reduction from twelve
point seven million pounds to talk to
point two million pounds section six
point three shows a debt repayment
profile for the next thirty years with
all debt being repaid by twenty forty
nine to twenty fifty a fundamental
review of the housing service has been
undertaken during twenty nineteen to
twenty to identify savings efficiencies
and income generation opportunities to
achieve a sustainable business plan into
the future when a scope of this review
is provided in Section seven point one
of the report we are continuing with
with our aspiration to increase our
housing stock new homes of all types
provide us with new homes bonus and
council tax but additional castle
housing also delivers rental income and
wider financial and social benefits the
table in Section ten point one of the
report sets out the HRA budget for 2020
to 2021 based on the 2.7 percent
rent increase and highlights the
movement from the
20 19 to 20 20 budget a surplus position
of 298,000 pounces forecasts which is a
significant improvement on last year
which showed deficit of one hundred and
ninety three thousand pounds and this
has been achieved by reducing both
revenue and capital budgets provided in
table 10.1 and we are proposing to
transfer the surplus to the hie reserves
income and savings opportunities that
have been made an are proposed to 2022
2021 I are identified in Section eight
point two we are proposing to increase
sheltered housing charges by two pound
per week to ensure a recovery of the
actual cost it is proposed that utility
charges are kept at the same level as
the current year garage rents or a
remain at the current level income
increases or savings continued to be
reflected in the budget and will be
monitored during the year next year
we'll see a focus on all contracts those
more than fifty thousand pounds to
review the terms of each of these and to
identify the savings opportunities as
well as a decision on the long-term
future of building services by a joint
venture with flagship housing a review
of the HRA business plan will also be
undertaken finally I'd like to note that
the right to buy sales were lower than
those projected in the business plan in
twenty eighteen to nineteen babe assault
fifteen against an original projection
of twenty seven sales moving on to the
capital program section five point four
the report summarizes the capital
expansion financing for the next four
years up to twenty twenty three to
twenty to twenty four the section of six
point four gives a graphical view of the
expenditure paragraph still employed
want eleven point three and the penet
say provide more detail on this working
with I seen you to identify development
sites we are ami to build two hundred
and twenty nine affordable homes of
fifteen for shared ownership we are
interested pacing a cumulative capital
program budget of just under fifty one
point two million pounds which includes
twenty six point nine million pounds for
the new builds and acquisitions devoted
to be financed from a number of sources
as shown as section five point four and
the appendix including eleven point
seven million pounds further borrowing
no strategic priority reserves will be
reduced to finance this pro
take a check thank you very much Council
award at the any officer comments only
at officer additions to make to that
right then members over to you we have a
very short paper but there's some quite
significant stuff in there any questions
oh well I'm gonna have one because I
mean I think one of the first thing was
this jumps out of course is the huge
increase in capital spend new build and
acquisitions in the years 2021 2022
since we have the cabinet member for
housing here as well and as well as the
finance team and and the Assistant
Director for housing it's probably as
good at the time as any to ask about how
the rollout of this would take place yes
Kevin Fisk Thank You chair so in
relation to the capital program yes
Weber are investing heavily in
development of new homes and we all know
justification and reasons but for that
the schemes coming forward in the very
near future obviously schemes in in
shortly
angel core brand firm amongst others we
have been working with I see me on that
pipeline of activity to ensure that at
any one time we have properties that we
are or land that we are identifying for
housing that we're going through the
planning process design and fruit to
being on site so I think over the next
couple of years you can continue you'll
continue to see that sort of progression
in terms of at any one time us working
diligently on building new homes at a
site or sites and those sites coming
forward in the meantime as well some
examples of that
going at the moment are the review of
Garage sites and possibly whether or not
those sites are so it will for us to
develop or for alternative uses
self-build is an example of of that but
it always comes back
to the fact that land is is is of of a
need obviously we have looked at and
identified as many of our HRA
opportunities as we can saying as we go
forward we'll be needing to identify
land opportunities to then in support
that house building councillor Dawson I
want just come back to you all this
business with the young garages and that
we've talked about this for a long time
and what's not natus recently so you had
a lot of problems with this in Hadley
and you say having a review and I talked
to one of the team about this any last
week and they've sits me quickly that
they're not reviewing it because what I
can't understand I have to say is we've
got 20 garages where they could be sites
for more affordable housing and
certainly unless you've got anything
bigger than a mini none of these cars
can get in these garages it's really
very very clear they're paying 800 pound
there were 700 I think a month
13:49 with it yes 700 a month and they
are used to storage and you know the
team have said to me or to you say quite
clearly they simply don't have enough
time so what is happening is people are
parking in front so not even using them
so why are you saying the team are
actually looking at these sides I don't
believe that's actually the case Gavin
so they told me okay thank you forcing
your microphone still on sorry Thank You
councillor Dawson for the question which
I hope I can answer so there is ongoing
piece of work involving the housing and
our assets team to review sites and
we've actually traffic-light all of our
sites in terms of a red amber and green
that's in relation to both supply and
demand for the site as well as potential
future costs in terms of maintaining
those garish sites and and so on there's
actually a report coming to admin
briefing in the next few weeks in
relation to garages
and that will summarize some of the work
that's been done we have had staff
vacancies and and that's been part of a
restructure within the housing team
which has left some some vacancy
management to manage but what we have
been able to do is we've have been able
to let any site where we have demand
where we struggle is where we've got
sites with empty garages and we've got
no demand and as we take that work
forward the briefing paper to admin
talks about actually trying to take a
different approach
so the weekly rent arm is about 11 or 12
pounds per week depending on where
you're a tenant or a non tenant of babe
District Council and as such actually we
may need to come back to cabinet and ask
ourselves a question yes there is a
revenue generation opportunity here or
there has been actually there is no
demand for this area house building may
or may not be a suitable alternative but
maybe an alternative is to look at
demolishing the garages and and making
those car parking spaces so a whole
range of different options being
considered at the moment for all of
those sites because so I can reassure
you that that work is going on and are
you considering um compulsory purchase
with a view which one could do for some
of these perhaps what is their more
rural to then use for housing affordable
housing again I think we're straying off
the area of the budget bunnies aren't
again just just very quickly so one of
the challenges that we have in bebo are
that we have our decisions were
historically made that we will let a
garage with a property it is turned to
compulsory let that means that our in
terms of the rent that the tenant pays
the cost of the garages is already
assumed that is payable by HB as well
and so therefore historic decisions were
actually supportive of maintaining as
much garage income as possible the fact
is though that as a result of compulsory
let as and when properties may be sold
through the rights by
the garages sold at the same time so we
do have the challenge with some of our
sites where actually they may be there
may be opportunity for redevelopment but
there would be a need to talk to garage
owners about about those decisions and
how we move that forward and where we
have done that we've been able to bring
forward sites and offer an alternative
parking provision to those to those
owner occupiers and those conversations
are going on now in certain sites that I
know am I right in thinking there might
be some legacy arrangements in place
that would preclude doing some things in
some circumstances because you've
different legal arrangements and
different agreements made in the past
yeah okay Castle McClaren can I can I
ask a questions when the budget is set
for the increase in rents and sheltered
housing costs looking at that that's
quite small but for many people that is
quite a lot of money do you this is not
really about housing but when you're
setting the budget do you look at the
impact that might have on the population
that we're actually serving and on
attendance is that sort of taken into
consideration councillor Ward I think
you can answer that one because I think
that actually speaks to the increases
councillor Osborne will speak on your
behalf in that case castle was born
thank you sir and thank you John yeah
actually I did
challenge the the increase the proposed
increase in the sheltered housing
charges because I was rather concerned
about it and when we looked into it the
actual at the moment
prior to this proposed increase the
sheltered the general needs
accommodation is actually subsidizing
the sheltered housing to a cost of
58,000 which is which is quite a lot of
money by increasing it by the two pounds
per week we then reduce that subsidy on
general needs to 31,000
you will note that we didn't increase
the charges last year in the 1920 budget
and we also are not proposing to
increase the utility charges so year it
is a concern but we have to balance out
on sheltered housing and on general
needs and that was the decision but we
did discuss it at length so yes it is
looked at and discussed at length
Gavan make Jed and just to add to Jan's
comments council warns it's a it's a
fact that rents have decreased
year-on-year for the last four years
it's a fact that in terms of diet or a
business plan it's based on both
five-year projections and 30-year
projections so actually rents in twenty
twenty twenty-one will actually less
than they were back in 2015 as a
monetary sum per week naturally we have
to look at what we need to provide the
services don't need to remind members
that the housing revenue account is
ring-fence
so any money generated coming in through
rents or service charges is actually
reinvested in the housing service
whether that be new homes or
improvements to the existing stock and I
think is providing that we can give
certainty that we are being is
financially efficient in in terms of
being responsible for that that income
and imagining in the best way then
that's the ratios I could give tenants
that that any increase as a result of a
need to to improve their homes so just
to summarize the that's the cumulative
effect of the 1% of cuts that has been
taking place the last few years and that
1% 1% 1% has been year on year on year
every year but now we're only increasing
2.7 percent but we actually haven't
recovered back the minus 1 minus 1 minus
1 and so on
yes that's correct yeah and I'd go on to
add that actually
decisions that were made in terms of the
1% reduction we've obviously managed and
mitigated against as I said housing
revenue account business plan is
predicated on a five-year 30-year
business plan
well in that business plan that it will
be projecting rents or it was back then
projector meant to probably increase in
by 2 3 4 percent per year per annum
year-on-year so actually if you were to
look back rents are far lower than they
would have been predicted at this stage
some five or six years ago one of the
net effects of this budget in its
referred to in the recommendation 3.6
without that's up to us but is a
budgeted surface of 298 thousand pounds
and that's to be transferred to the HRA
reserves for this coming financial year
I just wondered is that how much
significance does that amount will make
a significant difference to the HRA
reserves or is it just a pinprick thank
you chair so the report does detail
reserve balances I'm just trying to look
for the detail as to which table that is
in basically reserves are approximately
12 million pounds and some of the
conversations that I'll be having with
portfolio holders for housing and
cabinet in the not-too-distant future is
how we maximize those reserves and that
could be reinvestment in in new housing
and purchasing land or it could be on
significant improvement programs for our
tenants that will see the benefit in
terms of additional capital expenditure
on their homes thanks that's exactly
what I was driving at there's just a
very general thing because I again I was
looking at the graph that graph see
capital for a program and which
obviously shows the capital spend over
these years and though capital
maintenance is steadily increasing as it
should we have to preserve the housing
stock that we have
there is a sort of quatl of changes in
the new build and acquisitions with that
big peak in twenty twenty one twenty two
or twenty two which we've already
commented Oakland of two hundred and
twenty nine houses can only be welcomed
but one wouldn't want to see it stopped
there we wouldn't want that to be just a
one-off a blip so I was hoping for some
reassurance that we were considering
further builds can we confirm that we
are looking for some further builds okay
councillor Osborne as cabinet member for
housing perhaps you could ask yes Jenna
yeah I can confirm that 100% we will be
looking when you get thanks I think is
an important point to bring out I think
it's something that I've commented in
the past that British sort of English
and Welsh councils stopped building
council houses to a large extent 30 or
40 years ago and literally haven't done
so for many many years and they figures
and the BBC figure shown a couple of
years or less than a year ago which just
showed the dramatic amount of changes in
who builds what and who doesn't build
very much at all and a plummeting of the
figures for council houses across the
country council awarded that is true but
term stock holding authorities those
that still remain a stock holding
authorities across the country whatever
political persuasion are now embarking
on construction programs a lot of that
of course has been encouraged by the
fact that the the cap on on borrowing
has within hrs has been removed and
that's going to be a great help over the
years to come thanks very much for
pointing out it wasn't making a
political point I really genuinely was
talking about this as a study and there
was a series of articles they don't have
many people had a chance to see it on on
the housing situation in East Anglia in
the East Anglian whole week's articles
on the general subject of who all the
housing providers were and the freshers
and issues facing each one of those in
turn if you know nobody's seen it I'm
trying to get hold of a collection of
those articles they are really very well
done Gavin you had something to add
Thank You Jay just to add to that graph
B in the report
that projects the debt profile over the
next 30 years the dotted gray line is
the former debt cap that as a as a
housing authority we could not exceed
prior to the removal of the debt cap the
Green Line shows you a Prudential debt
limit that we have set to maintain that
we can afford any debt that we borrow
and also they will be reviewing that in
due course as well but you can see that
actually the removal of debt cap has
allowed us to borrow more money to
invest in new homes and that's
everything in that graph is that
dramatically affected by the rise in the
public sector absolutely Public Works
board we have Donna detailed review
based on PWL berates
it does affect the business plan over
the 30 years by approximately five
million pounds but that that's over over
obviously first over 30 years and also
it depends on where we're looking for to
that borrowing in terms of short or long
term borrowing and obviously any
borrowing within the housing revenue
account it is part of the medium-term
financial strategy that cancels I mean
in that particular section of graph B I
have to say it is obvious that the area
above the dotted line just shows the
difference that removal of the debt cap
has made in terms of the potential of
what could be done so thank thank you
for that I just wanted to bring that
point out because I think it's a very
important one and if you talk about the
HRA it's probably the most important one
Cass Lord yeah and and in terms of where
the borrowing is Islam or short term and
to the extent we need to dip into the
PWR B and the impact of the 1% increase
I think it's true to say Catherine isn't
it the new government municipal bonds
which there are recently announcing or
have recently announced term with a
lower interest rate than p WL b is that
correct yes there I think the first one
is being issued to Lancashire I think
so that is finally up and running the LG
I have been trying to get this off the
ground for about three or four years now
so that's another potential source of
borrowing that we can we can look at
going forward as well right
members any other questions any other
comments before we move to well what
recommendations we believe we should
make now there are six presented as
suggestions here again these are the
same ones that were seen an ad cabinet
and were adopted by a cabinet but again
we can change them if we have any
observations we make I'm always very
cautious it's like this attorney I mean
none of us are going to have worked out
what it's changing to 2% we weren't a
cost it event so let's be careful with
what we say but there are six
recommendations in front of us they
range from the HRA proposal itself to
the increasing capsule house rents the
garage rents beans get the same a
sheltered housing service being
increased to ensure I add that just from
what you saying
Castle Osborne that in fact we are will
still be subsidizing the sheltered
housing just not the same extent as
before cutting it and maybe what 40% of
that the subsidy costs something like
that we're still paying sixty percent
that the forty percent for that we had
slight reduction okay so that's that's
about a hundred pounds a year really
isn't it yeah effectively yeah two
pounds a week it's a hundred pounds a
year more or less and then the utility
charge is being kept at the same level I
mean nobody's going to argue with three
point three or three point five I would
imagine any thoughts any proposals any
recommendations members less
if we can frame some recommendations
Kessler Osborne thank you Miss Joe just
3.7 the right to buy receipts I'm really
a bit I thought just some clarification
of how
Beiber's stood with this and what would
be the what is the position as we go
forward on writer bite is there any
knowledge of that yeah an abuser
something on that one yeah thank you
Jess so that recommendation in principle
is just that obviously the percentage of
right to buy receipts that we can retain
as a local authority are reinvested in
in new homes rather than potentially
holding on to those receipts and then
having to give them back to the central
government we've interest I can reassure
members that we are proactively spending
right to buy receipts were also
balancing right to buy receipts in terms
of investment in new homes with homes
England gran and and evaluating when and
where it's more appropriate to use right
to buy receipts or grant that is
available but we have spent all of our
receipts and projecting those being
spent going forward so we don't project
that will need to be giving any receipts
back anytime soon and to clarify that
our right to buy receipts not not the
totality we only get a proportion 30%
yeah which seems a bit strange when it's
our housing stock there you go so that's
thank you for bringing up 3.7 and the
final poem missed was the 3.8 which is
the revised HRA business plan in
Appendix B which it says suggests that
they promote it unless any one of us
wants to pick that apart suggested that
we straight forward so can we have the
proposal or whether we could take these
recommendations as they're suggested or
whether we should alter them in any way
counselor or squad yeah Thank You mr.
chairman yes I'd very much like to
propose the recommendations as listed
and thank you for the clarification
going of 3.7 and once again can I add my
goodwill goodwill but thanks to your
housing team and all the other officers
involved I think you've done really
really well to produce and go forward as
you have done judging by the contents of
this report Thank You councillor McLaren
it was one suggestion to your resolution
um three point nine which would be that
we or you'd be adding three point nine
that we congratulate whatever what was
the expression we used last time as we
added er thanks but also was it a
commendation or is it commendation yeah
compliment at the finance complement
work conducted that says something
similar to that but I'd also just like
to add to that that note note this
satisfaction the proposed capital
expended the proposed new bills of two
hundred twenty nine houses I think that
is something that should be included in
the recommendations actively and promote
it as such and say I believe that's a
good news story there are some
straightforward matter of business
things I'd be happy to vote for that but
we have a proposer and a secondary are
you happy with that amendment councillor
Osborn yes thank you Miss cherry yes I'm
very much in favor of that Amendment and
we drafted some way honestly yeah note
note note with satisfaction in the group
building of the house it's just
something like that okay that's address
I think as much as we can say all right
so any other proposals there any other
changes that anybody wants to make all
right so all those in favor of the
proposal for those nine recommendations
then again is carried unanimously
I'd like to thank that everybody here
today that's really useful to go through
I'm yet right we did go through the
nitpicking stuff but I think that's
partly the Java scrutiny is to take the
taking pieces and put it back together
again so thanks Bill the offices is
coming along today thanks to the cabinet
members for introducing and commenting
and we'll now move on to the next part
of the edge Brittany agenda we have no
information bulletin which will be item
eight so the forthcoming decisions list
is an item that I would like to go
through if members have got a moment to
turn to that does anybody want a short
break of any reason we haven't filled a
while to do so anybody want five minutes
come to the break note we'll carry on
them so if you could turn to the forward
plan because of the time we lost or
rather the time spent in Toyotas during
the general election period and then the
gap caused by Christmas and New Year I
think we slightly lost track where we
were as our work plan and so I just like
to run through that at the moment at the
moment we have down for February B MBS
and the proposed development of the
building services case is a I'm slightly
slightly difficult for me I presume we
put on this and I can't really attend
this in February I'm doing surgery in
London what I would say what I would say
this is a business is find a substitute
from your group but I'm just all three
into attentions you're only going to
have two people in the neck so knows we
do we obviously have two other members
that what but what game ecology is one
of them anyways you're quite happy no no
no I mean substitutes would be
encouraged so I'm no but I appreciate
that with this being a fairly small
committee now and the council being
reduced in size we have this issue for
example if a member of a very small
group who can't make a meeting and
there's only one other member there's
only one other member to to substitute
I understand
I mean we've set our timings up at the
start of the year of Corpus ly I think I
think that's something for you to
discuss with your group leader if that's
a problem well yeah absolutely but it's
not something we should probably discuss
in meeting hey I just want you clear
about this because is it would you mind
if I turned up 20 minutes late if I went
in future or is there a problem because
otherwise I have to find someone else it
only becomes a problem if there had been
anything earlier on the agenda like a
declaration of an interest which hasn't
happened as yet but you always have the
option you always have the option to
record to bring up a declaration of
interest at any point in a meeting so
from that point of view it's no issue we
are not a decision-making body in that
sense there's no it's not like it's not
like a planning meeting so from a
governance point of view I can't see any
problem with that not to to to and vote
at that point but I mean it is a she say
it's not a decision-making so it's okay
for you to come in and comment and
you're not taking a decision so it's a
judgment call and of course what we're
doing is we're applying our judgment and
our scrutiny to and I've to know it's
always assumed that everybody seen the
papers so that they've got a pretty fair
idea of what we've been discussing and
the initial part of any meeting or any
item is in fact explaining what was
already in the papers or reiterating
what was already in the papers so but we
have to do that we have to because not
everybody has access to the papers
this is broadcast on YouTube there's
even the possibility somebody might
watch this you never don't never can
tell but let's move on to that general
point about this item B & Bs and they
proposed development building services
business case the only reason I bring
this up is that this will be the third
time that we have looked at a business
case for B & Bs and there's a new model
being proposed which I would really like
to see as many people turning up for as
possible because this has become a
current issue and it's a considerable
concern to the council it affects all
our tenants it affects us reputationally
and it has been through some difficult
times to say the least alright it's an
area that needs a particular attention
likewise the other item on that February
meeting which will be captured by
councilor well them as a joint meeting
is on planning enforcement which and I
hope you've seen the new reports which
we're receiving weekly I hope on
planning enforcement cases but this is
going to be more of an in-depth study
from the chief planning officer of how
enforcement is working and how it's
going to work and I think this addresses
a concern I hear from members across the
whole council and of course across knit
Suffolk as well but generally speaking
most people have different views about
what planning enforcement means and the
paper is designed to address that so
Adrienne and I both had discussions with
Phyllis Bell just to discuss how it's
going to be brought forward the next
joint meeting after that brings us to
customer access point activity again
there's a follow-up on how well the
outreach centers do you know the places
in various of dots and apps don't mark
it sub free the pop ups taking place in
shortly and it had Lee how well they
going and that would be councillor
Parker I think presenting that and then
the housing delivery test action plan
again is a follow up where we're going
to be scrutinizing an action plan that
was previously discussed and this is how
we measure and test if we are actually
delivering the houses that we're
supposed to there will be a very
interesting item on the 23rd of March
which I believe may attract some public
interest and this is something that has
been asked for from sudbury direction
for some time I've had emails I'm sure
many other members have and it's on
Bellevue house
if this is review of the plans for
Bellevue house it will not necessarily
be in greed involved in all aspects of
going things going on in Bellevue Park
as I understand it this is specifically
on Bellevue house should it change at
any time
obviously well we'll find out but we'll
let everybody know that's Roz balm you
wanted to say something yes thank you
mr. chair we'll just just the fact is
that the park has got no relevance to
anything to do with the house the green
and there's an engagement going forward
which I believe is the end of this month
sometime so therefore this is a
well-planned item to scrutinize after
those plans have already been engaged by
local residents etc but yeah and the
proposals which would come fortunate I
think I think I think we're all aware
that there's considerable public
interest in that and and then there's
also considerable public confusion and a
lot of separate items have become
conflated into one case and I think it's
important that if nothing else scrutiny
can do is we can actually say no this is
one thing that's another and perhaps
even that's another and that's our job
is to throw light on to a situation
rather than making things darker now
just yes that's one yeah absolutely
agree with you there's a number of items
around Bellevue Park itself and the
swimming pool area which has got no
relevance to the park at all again and
also Hamilton Road which again is
another engagement of what what the
intentions are to to to Peter
absolutely one of those areas where
you've got the local knowledge I don't
I'd be quite honest about it but that's
one of the reasons why we have so many
of us scrutinizing it as councillor
dorsum will probably have know a little
bit more than I do visits
Hadley's Hadleys closer to Sudbury you
use your microphone counselor door still
isn't clear I thought all this was all
gonna be on that size isn't it
if this just Bellevue or is it the rest
of it as well no I just said that its
belly house specificity is what we're
looking at the plans and I wanted to
make that point quite firmly that there
are separate issues involved in separate
pieces which some of which as Adrienne
has pointed out we will not be
discussing unless of course it gets
changed I'm just going through the
program at the moment Mary could I
suggest I I know about Bellevue house
but I really don't know really the
ramifications right okay which is what
the report did not I suggest that we as
a group meet with counselor Osborn and
Platts II could explain to us or
somebody explain to us from Sudbury what
the actually because we we just that we
just read this and because I'm from this
side of the district I'm not familiar
with the other arguments that are going
on I don't I don't think I mean I
believe me I'm there's no problem
talking to any member from any area at
any time I mean basically that no reason
why individuals can't meet we could
include that if you wanted to but I mean
frankly I think a briefing in a scrutiny
committee means that all the information
must be equally shared and they open to
all I wouldn't want to think that
anybody is being briefed in advance
beyond what they could find out from
other members I mean I'm frankly that's
probably the best route we should the
people who are against their view should
we not be listening to their view as
well then it may be that we call those
witnesses but we haven't decided that as
yet that's effectively what I'm trying
to say is that this item is on the
agenda but it will be specifically about
this item the actual work program
caseros born and I will be discussing in
the chairs briefings along with well
because this is an exclusively Baber
issue it will almost it will be a
Bayboro meeting rather than a joint
meeting that's the one for the 23rd of
March well the witness
coming then what do you call them in on
it from the other side that's what the
chairs meetings are there to discuss is
to decide as to what we think they were
irrelevant and who we wouldn't want to
invite to act as witnesses to to inform
us so that we actually can give proper
due consideration and make balanced
recommendations on that so then I'm
drawing your attention to this because
it's only the 23rd of March it's two
months away so the sooner we start
thinking about it the better
Castle McClaren I just feel the rest of
the two of the members are not here and
not from that part of the world either
it's irrelevant where they're from you
know but to give a detailed that would
be would largely be the job of the
scrutiny committee in scrutiny there's
nothing to stop anybody finding out
anything they want to beforehand but I'm
not proposing to organise a formal
briefing from one side or another I
think members of the members have to
take that responsibility onto themselves
frankly we have more than enough
meetings on particular aspects and you
can hear whatever you you know from one
side or one group we obviously cranky
people therefore we would be helpful
obviously we would be looking to do just
that I mean that's fundamentally what we
do we do actually look for witnesses
that can throw light onto a situation
and sometimes we actually find the
witnesses learn something themselves
sometimes we learn a lot more
we just see how it goes but they're just
we keep an open mind but we do realize
that we're talking about one specific
thing and if somebody starts talking
about something else I'm quite clear as
chair that I will say I'm sorry this and
that's not what we're discussing here so
I'm drawing your attention to that right
now that final joint meeting the
underspend of for grants for bringing
empty homes back into use is something
that's been discussed and referred to
peripherally today about empty houses
well as a grant it's being under spent
let's see how we can look at getting it
properly spent why some I would like to
draw his attention to this again isn't a
and I'm thinking ahead here is
representatives on outside bodies now
last year we invited counselors to fill
out a survey form return to Henriette
here and some members actually did so
and we provided the beginnings of a
database this year I won't proposing
that we will publicize it a great deal
earlier as in starting around now and
that the that we send a message I will
send a message out to all members with
their forms and we'll start if not this
month in February so that we have
receipt of those forms in February and
March ready for April because otherwise
we don't have enough of data to work on
and we'll stress it now there are fewer
members and there are about the same
number of outside groups but it's not a
difficult thing to fill out but we just
need people to do so because a lot of
members are working away not telling
anybody about it and I'm not suggesting
any members are on these groups are not
going to anything we just need to get
the information so that we can sign
I suppose idea of what the value of each
representation is and the final one at
the moment is the 18th of May which is a
sort of review of the year now we
generally scrutinize ourselves to some
extent oh you've got something to add
haven't you if there's a new item yes
yes just to let you know that we've been
asked to adjoint home and Housing
Strategy to the meeting in May as well
would that be part of the corporate
outputs and stuff okay we've been
looking at the strategy as well at that
meeting obviously we have lots of
strategies but this is going to be a
strategy on housing not planning housing
sorry chair will be a review of the work
conducted throughout nineteen 2019 and
2020 and listened
achievements right so basically we're
not only looking at our own work in the
past year we're looking at the housing
strategy work in the past year as well
and the reason I mention all this stuff
is because there is one suggested item
John Osborne here has written to both
chairs and and suggested something that
she thinks could scrutiny could usefully
do which we could add value to which is
a very of some importance the council do
you want to speak on this Jan yes
Democratic relationship is like out in
the community and I think it's fair to
say that although we've been here now
for two years and we are you know
focusing on locality arrangements and
place-based working there's still some
perceptions within the community that
the council is still remote from our
communities and that that's not just
with our residents but also with that
within our town and parish councils and
I think it's fair to say so I've
suggested that we have a look at really
you know what our levels of
participation are what we want them to
be what sorts of types of things we
could we could do to improve that and I
think it would be a really good topic
for overview and scrutiny to look at I
mean there's lots of initiatives that we
could go out to there's things like I
saw things we done a little bit with our
marketplace stuff around local democracy
week where we went out and had a
marketplace stools so we could we could
build on that we could look at things
like youth councils youth forums where
we build that relationships with schools
I know we had a webinar there in here
for democracy week and the schools are
quite keen to build that relationship
but there is some work about getting
them engaged to do that so it's all
around that and then this is a say
there's there's other things we could do
we could have a great debate we could
have run campaigns to to become a
counselor
even because you know even across you
know the very grassroots level the
parish councils they struggle to get
cancers and so it's about selling the
message about what what you do do and
you know how you can improve your local
community but it's things like toolkits
to assist people it's improving
information having public forums and
better consultation events so we can
look at all of that there's a whole raft
I mean even introducing a staff
volunteering scheme where we as staff go
out and help the local communities so
there's lots of things we could do and I
think it's a really good subject that's
the point I mean it's from a point of
view of democratic services but it's
also I think during recent events
there's been some deception of people
think there's a democratic deficit there
are shortages in democracy and there are
unless we explain ourselves and we
actually communicate and contact people
better and what we're going to sorry
what you think we're way off ball a bit
with this because all we're all going to
schools but certainly you know being in
an urban and I'm sure you can't
transport it's the same problem
it's the accessibility into baby you
know we have made presence when people
to call it that the access into for the
public including myself is just a
nightmare
it's an absolute nightmare and it means
specifically getting to hips which
issues with their council sex their
waists it does absolutely anything they
can't get in and discuss it with people
and my my what really bothers me about
this is we get these things that keep
coming back sort of saying well we've
discussed it and we don't really and and
I think discuss having a big
conversation impression is my impression
is that's not really thought people want
they want to be able to access favor
which they can't you know we aren't we
don't have a presence there they can't
do it through you know is a nightmare
going on a computer I know myself
actually if you order you trying to get
through this environment or you know you
think oh if you've got an issue you're
not quite sure where to go and it's more
the practical
access and I think if we can resolve
that I think you're fighting I just
think going out into schools and home I
think they think that's an example but
what we're discussing here isn't the
specific various questions and answers
and things what I'm trying to suggest is
that this is an item we should consider
and it's something is accessibility from
the pot as you see it my point is this
I'm not actually saying we should
discuss it here and now what I'm saying
is that I think you should be that
should be part of what's on the agenda
and the anything is going to be part of
what's on the agenda that's the point
nothing is ruled out and this is what
I'm getting to is that my proposal is
this that we include for the course of
the next few meetings to explain the
situation Jan here has a office of
support available from June now we don't
want to wait till June to discuss this
it start to important it's fairly clear
that there are issues and something some
people don't have those issues some
people do what issues there are what
observations all counselors have made is
something that could be looked at on a
regular basis now scrutiny is a good
place to start this process what I'm
suggesting is that into our work plan
over the course of the next few months
starting with probably the February
meeting could we accommodate and I'm
suggesting a regular recurring item on
the agenda where we start raising what
the questions are not what the answers
are what the questions and what the
issues are and we carry it forward in
other words we give Jan here a head
start in producing the report that will
eventually start the ball rolling on
actually what we do but what we do will
depend very much on the input coming
from here and I'll add I've also had
discussions of cabinet members to get
their input and their thoughts on this
because I see no reason not to do that
and as far as I'm concerned and as far
as any of us should be concerned this
should be open to all members across the
whole Council but where they're out of
the you know in the parishes and in the
towns and if we don't know what people
concerns and worries are what
councillors are
nobody does so this is the way to do it
it's an idea to work with Democratic
services to basically address a
Democratic deficit I mean whatever form
it might take but we've got to start it
and there must be a process and I'm
proposing that's how we approach it with
a regular updated item not necessarily
coming to any conclusions but just
raising the questions producing the data
the ideas and then Janice got something
to work with because otherwise it's
going to be just what John thinks or
it's just going to be what I sing for
it's just going to your counselor Dawson
thinks or whatever if any one of us did
that well that's all we'd end up with
what we want to do is get what everybody
thinks and then we know where we've got
some where we start so that's the
proposal and I'll be discussing it
further at the chairs meetings but I
just wanted to run that by you and hope
that you'd see that see the purpose
behind it yeah yeah it's just generally
if we don't do this who is it who's
going to do it there were some items
identified for review but they're not
currently timetable these I just like to
update these the disabled facilities
grant is actually ready underway to side
large extent in fact decisions have been
made recently to increase the maximum
disabled facilities grants from five
thousand to seven and a half thousand
pounds and that was done by a delegated
decision and as it just adopted so it
didn't get off to a great start it's
being publicized now but it's no real
purpose in our continuing to keep this
on our untime tabled list because it's
largely been dealt with
unless anything changes dramatically the
crime and disorder panel which is down
here as being for September October 2020
we were delayed because of the general
election in our own timetable and that
the inability some of the witnesses
couldn't make the original proposed time
it got put back to October or November
above which time the general election
intervened and everything popped into
January
now we've held our crime and disorder
panel me
in our annual review statutory
requirement for this year that was only
last month's know was this Manson
suspense good heavens it all goes so
quickly really do it's not like in the
situation is going to change
dramatically in the year 2020 however we
would still be within the statutory
period if we did it held held the next
review in 2021 as long as it's before
the end of the council year so the
proposal would be to move that to
February of 2021 is that correct so
every or March 2021 depending upon
availability of the relevant witnesses I
also understand that the by that time
there will be a new chair of the
Community Safety Partnership the west of
southwestern that Suffolk Community
Safety Partnership which will probably
be give them time to get themselves into
the job so that'll be uff use other
items the joint complement command
comments and complaints policies a
recurring item which we're going to get
an update on it maybe after that we
don't need to look at it again if we
think it is well enough in place but
we'll have to see what the report says
and there was one item we're going to be
looking at this Adrian and myself and
the other chairs of the next chairs
meeting which is in a couple of weeks
time third of every three weeks time no
two weeks time we'll be considering the
improving access to the private rented
sector at that meeting and trying to
work out where we could slot it in to
now it's a very difficult subject
because the honest truth is the
government are looking at legislation at
this very minute and will continue to be
looking at it for the next six months at
least so it's not it's questionable
whether were there's any that's a moot
point whether we should be discussing
something which could change overnight
so we'll have to look at that then and
that more or less covers everything that
I've got on our work plan for this year
and is there anything else in the agenda
there that was just a mix-up like one
which is not really a issue so at that
point I think we've completed everything
on the agenda thanks very much for
coming today
sorry enjoyed so much and see you at the
next meeting in February probably about
a month from now I think you've actually
should notice the 20th of February joint
meeting we'll be looking at the MBS
building services business case and
planning enforcement thanks again